renowned brain surgeon and best-selling
author ben Carson is the candidates who
came from nowhere to the front of the
pack the only african-american in the
races charmed his party with his
softly-spoken rags-to-riches story
freedom is not free the hardscrabble boy
from Detroit to became a world leading
neurosurgeon in an age when voters
distrust the political establishment
Carson's pitching himself as the man
from outside the mainstream with views
to match whether it's comparing obama
care to slavery or saying that giving
jews guns would have stopped the
Holocaust or claiming wrongly but China
is involved in the conflict in Syria
he's the candidate who's not afraid to
say what he thinks can he remain as a
contender or will the committed
Christian with ten best sellers to his
name I'm a presidential